all right guys what's up
man peter what's going on dude
dude what's going on with you hey this
is the first time i've seen you since
you've been married dude
i know thank you how did that go
uh it was fascinating i enjoyed it i'm
excited
we got married in the middle of a uh
pandemic
in new york city and it was just polina
and i
uh my brother was the minister or the
officiant or whatever it's called
and uh he started off the uh
ceremony if you want to call it that
with uh family friends thank you so much
for coming
and making the long trek to this
momentous occasion
hey well you saved a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah oh trust me we're we're still gonna
have like a
a real um kind of bigger uh celebration
it was gonna be small to begin with only
50 people so um
not uh not not a huge operation i've
been to weddings that are like
you know 400 people you're just like
dude are you are you doing this for
yourself are you doing this for the 400
people who are here yeah
i think they're usually doing it for the
girl that marion
that's a that's a whole nother thing
right yeah because you were married
before right
yeah for three months how did you do the
wedding
we had a we had a big wedding in london
we're not huge like 80 people
uh we got married at westminster
register office where paul mccartney got
married
like a really cool place and then we had
the reception at um
what was it called um some pegarus hotel
which is uh
king's cross station beautiful place um
but
yeah that didn't really work out for me
you might you might even be longer
longer married now than i was
now only three weeks only three weeks so
far uh what what uh what what are your
thoughts on bitcoin so far
last night we're recording this on
sunday uh i think we're gonna release in
a couple of days but uh
last night bitcoin just absolutely
ripping people's faces off and then
dumping
yeah well i thought it would at 12 i
didn't know
i've kind of stopped that whole play
playing the kind of market thing and
trying to tell tops and bottoms my my
bitcoin investment strategy right now is
accumulate hold and i've said i i wasn't
going to sell any
for unless i had to i did but i wasn't
going to sell any for three halvings
we've had one
recently so i've got two more halvings
i'm not going to sell any for so
i took like quite a long time horizon i
thought it might dump at 12.
listen i you there was a time i had a
fair amount of bitcoin back in 2017 and
i [ __ ] up and lost like 80 percent
just
by mining equipment and trading bitcoins
and just being a [ __ ]
and then like i stopped all that i sold
all my [ __ ] coins i went bitcoin only
and then in the last year i've grown my
bitcoin stack by like
40 percent okay yeah and
and that means like i've got more than i
had i i can't have less
i'm not going to lose any and therefore
let's see where we are in 10 years so
like even though it did dump i'm cool
with that
what about you i'm the exact same way i
only accumulate
i've been saying for a long time it's
just a game of accumulation it's a fixed
supply asset uh
how do you think about um like
not necessarily portfolio construction
but just like when you're buying bitcoin
do you
uh are you obsessive about like hey
every two weeks uh on this day at this
time i put a certain amount of money in
or do you just kind of opportunistically
um
uh acquire more bitcoin so i
only earn it now yeah
so interesting explain that well andreas
talked about it he said the best bitcoin
you get the one you earn
right it's the one you earn so a couple
of things happen you'll find this quite
interesting so what i do is like with my
sponsors
i've always got at least one sponsor
wants to pay in bitcoin and what i used
to do
is um i used to convert 75
to cash to run my business pay my team
and then keep 25
in bitcoin and that's why i was able to
accumulate some
then about a week and a half ago when
bitcoin was like 9-3
one of my clients paid their bill and it
was a quarterly bill
and paid in bitcoin and i was like you
know what i'm gonna leave this time for
a couple of weeks i'm gonna see what
happens
and then obviously we shot up now so
strangely i'm not like thinking oh i'm
going to sell that 75
now because i'm in profit on that
bitcoin i just leave it on my balance
sheet so
as i manage my business i have my cash
in the bank
uh uh cash out on invoice and then i
have my bitcoin
right and i might not just leave that
bitcoin on the balance sheet if that
never goes below
below 9 300 it doesn't matter what
happens yeah we'll always hit a 9
300 that stays on the balance sheet and
whether that goes to 20 30 40k bitcoin
doesn't matter
so so yeah so i only own bitcoin and i
also
i've i've heard some playing poker this
last few weeks
yeah have you seen this poker game no
what is it
you said it's a chris organizer it's
like a bunch of bitcoin is playing poker
um like charlie lee's there um
he always comes to play his brother
bobby's there sometimes luke martin's
there so we play every thursday we play
and i think i've earned like three
bitcoin what what are the uh buy-ins
it's like point three bitcoin like this
we it's point one but you need to have
point three it's a point one sit down
yeah and then you can you can you can
rebuy so everyone says that point three
we've been paying for like i think 13 14
weeks i'm like three bitcoin up
it's not bad yeah so it's all earned
bitcoin i only i only earn bitcoin now
and like i say i've done about 40 up
this year and that's what i'll continue
to do and
like i thought it would dump at 12. the
12 seemed like a number it would
um and also we went up we went from nine
to
12 pretty quick like we were overbought
right yeah
well i don't really pay attention so
much to all of like the underlying
daily metrics we're gonna some people
watch like rsi and kind of all that
stuff
um so i don't know kind of what all that
was showing uh but we definitely went up
very quickly from
you know nine ninety five hundred to
twelve thousand um
but i mean look it's one of these things
where there's only so many assets in the
world that go up twenty thirty percent
in you know a week literally dump 1500
in seconds and then recover 700 in
you know a minute later like yeah just
you know bitcoin is bigger you can't
play that [ __ ] anyway listen i've got a
question for you there's something else
we should have done before that
all right i want to talk to you about
roger veer all right let's do it
of course i want to talk to you about
that okay so firstly i didn't listen to
all of it
and what i did listen to actually it
seemed okay
it was better than i expected the reason
i didn't listen to all of it
is because it was nothing new what every
time so i had it on and i kept going
back i was like i've heard all this
before so i
give it ten minutes to come back and
it's like like i've heard it all before
um from him so i didn't listen to like
the last half
what did you get out of it so
obviously uh when obviously
i agreed to uh to do this uh
and roger agreed to do this it's not a
secret to him or i that it would be
uh heavily scrutinized right and
um because of that i took it you know
overly serious right more serious than i
normally take things
uh when i do these types of interviews
and i reached out to some people
i got uh some ideas in terms of what i
should uh
should ask about um on top of that i
also
got um you know quite a bit
of feedback from the audience on twitter
etc
and frankly 80 90 of the comments
were very much like scammer right it's
like oh okay
like fine if that's your opinion
whatever but like why right and that's
what i'm trying to get at was like
kind of get to layers two three four
five of the argument
and some people were able to clearly
articulate that and so
first of all to rogers credit like i
asked him a lot of questions i think
people
want answers to and he didn't
not answer them really he answered the
questions and so um
things like you know uh his portfolio
construction his thought process behind
uh why he did certain things uh what it
would take for him to come back to
bitcoin and kind of
um you know identify or admit that
bitcoin cash uh didn't work and
things that um you know it's very hard
to have a conversation with somebody
about
what is obviously sensitive topics uh
when
you're being combative with somebody
right and so you know you and i've
talked about it a bunch of times before
it's just like that's not my style right
is i i'll bring people on
i'm going to be respectful hopefully
they'll be respectful back and
are there times where people say things
and maybe i don't push back as much as
somebody who who wants to be combative
will be sure
but at the same time you know that's
kind of what the audience is there for
right is that they let people know on
twitter whatever
and so i actually think that
my biggest takeaways were one you can't
deny what roger did in the early days of
bitcoin
right before bitcoin uh two he has a
uh very rational thought process
behind a number of decisions he made
what i do think and i said it to him is
we just have a difference of opinion as
to whether that was a good
thought process in decision making or
not um and
the part that again you got to give him
credit for is like at the end we kind of
wrapped it up and said all right
there's two views of the world here's
why i believe my view here's why you
believe yours
ultimately neither one of our opinions
matter the market will decide
and so far the market is deciding that
bitcoin is the winner and will be the
winner
uh and roger's basically betting on the
fact that that's going to change in the
future but understands
you know that that may not happen um and
so if that
is kind of the path we go down then i
think at some point he would he would
come back to bitcoin
yeah it's kind of i yeah i'm not sure if
you'll come back to bitcoin i'm not sure
but i think he will hmm i asked him that
before
and he said he said he'd probably go off
and do something else i'm not sure he
will
i'm not but you know i have um let me go
let me go back a step
there's always nuance to some of this
stuff right yes and especially when
you're doing an interview and i know
what you mean about the combative stuff
when i did the brian armstrong interview
i knew there were a group of people who
wouldn't like it and they made a
decision to dislike it before it
happened
and the reason i knew that is like there
was some really good progress in that
interview
um yeah what they did is they found the
bits they didn't like picked it out and
just complained about it so i know i
knew those [ __ ] wouldn't like it
beforehand
and you know whatever to them but but
you have to construct an interview in a
respectful way and you want it bitter to
and fro you know
i know it right um but the thing
about and about roger is like i actually
have some sympathies
for him for some old stuff
right um so i have some sympathies for
him
bitcoin became something was different
from what he expected
but that does that all the time bitcoin
does that all the time to a bunch of
different people right and you just have
to accept that and he couldn't accept
that
but he was so sold on this idea that
bitcoin is kind of cash
cheap fast payments and it just became
something else
something possibly far more valuable now
some people are always saying that i
i think it's disingenuous if you look at
the bitcoin white paper
if you're gonna scream about how great
satoshi is this gift he gave to the
world i think you have to be honest and
look at the white paper
you talked about online commerce you
talked about cash
so i think i i think you have to
understand that some people believe
that's what they were building
and then perhaps it was both things
perhaps in something else so i had some
sympathy about that
my biggest issue and this is actually
more towards roger it's kind of like
when do you move on from this dude like
when do you accept what's happened and
just move on like focus on bitcoin cash
stop fighting you're not you he's you're
not gonna change bitcoin by
shouting it anymore yeah but but i think
that that that was kind of like
when i went into the interview and um
yeah i talked to him beforehand before
he even did the interview and i think
both of us
because we knew would be so heavily
scrutinized and all this stuff like we
both kind of just wanted to feel it
feel it out of like are we both going to
be respectful here you know kind of
where do our differences lie and really
just make sure that it would be frankly
worth
our time to record it and also too for
the audience to to listen
um and i think the piece that uh was
very clear was uh it's kind of like when
you're a kid
and let's say you've got a sibling if
you're nice to them
for the majority they're gonna be nice
back right if you
go over there and you know with a wiffle
ball bat whack them in the head
like you're gonna end up on the ground
brawling right like like it's kind of
like
you know you especially if you're the
older person right or you're the person
who's kind of
um initiating something and so same
thing with an interview right if
uh you get on and all of a sudden you're
just you're trying to
get somebody with gotcha questions and
poke them and and
catch them doing things whatever it's
like yeah sure of course they're going
to be on edge of course they're going to
be
overly defensive of course they're going
to be a little bit more aggressive back
but if instead you just say look i just
want to go through all of all of this
and uh i actually want you to walk away
from this saying
i was able to put my thoughts and ideas
on the record
and also uh be able to hear the other
side and so
a couple of times during the interview i
literally asked him i said hey
okay you just described what you believe
and you just described you know for the
let's say the block
uh dispute you just described why
uh something else happened what is the
argument of the other side of the table
like can you flip around and basically
tell me
the people you disagree with what's
their argument and to his credit like
yeah he can actually very in great
detail
explain not only his argument but also
he can explain the argument of the
people that
uh he disagrees with and i think that is
a sign of not only one
intelligence and kind of emotional
intelligence but also uh
three is just like he understands the
problems right
and that's kind of where i think you
know people who listen to it they're
like wait a second like this is a
conversation that roger hasn't had
before of just
he's showing that he understands there's
two sides to this argument he's betting
on one side there's people betting on
the other side and the market's going to
decide
right and so far the market has leaned
not in roger's favor
but i think the other piece that people
have to walk away from this and
you know he talks about it but but
doesn't quantify it is he says he's a
bad trader
right and and so if you kind of back out
of that like he lost a lot of money
doing this right so kind of his um
belief in something
came with upside and downside and so far
he's experienced the downside
and you know to his credit like he talks
about that right and
and he was very kind of um transparent
about it and
and forthcoming and so it's you know one
of these things where
uh people are complicated
you know creatures right like we're just
human and so there's things that you can
like about somebody there's things that
you can disagree with or not like
uh and in roger's case i think that
there's a lot of people who
are trying to put a binary you know good
or bad label on
um but if you look at it from the
historical context
you know there's a lot of people who
wouldn't be here without roger's work
in bitcoin um and then on the same side
there's a lot of things that
um you know i asked him about
specifically like using bitcoin.com but
people buying
bitcoin cash and you know and he
described
his thought process as to um you know
what what they're doing or the logic
there and people can decide whether they
think that's an acceptable answer or not
but
i think that's the key is just people
are complicated figures right
yeah i wonder how it plays out for him
um like i said i have a lot of sympathy
for
for early the early things he did he did
a lot of things to help bitcoin and i
had some sympathies for for things not
going his way
but obviously a lot of that gets eroded
away over time you just see somebody
repeating the same arguments
yeah causing a bit of trouble a bit of
mischief etc
um but i'm not like the type of person
who's just gonna sit there
and just be like hey to you i [ __ ] you i
want everything to go
to [ __ ] for you um yeah so and i
understand why some people have they've
got
you know real ptsd around what happened
with
uh segwit2x you know there's a real fear
of a takeover of bitcoin and
and and you know roger's involvement in
certain things around that period of
time
but i just wonder how it'll play out for
him because i don't think bitcoin cash
has much of a future
as if i think it has a future of
something that can be traded but
you know i think it's very hard to build
a cryptocurrency that lots of people
use regularly a bitcoin is kind of
amazing that it is you so
you know i actually strangely enough i
actually do use bitcoin quite a bit
now i'd probably do in terms of send and
receive
15 to 20 transactions a month now and
that's actually just
yeah using bitcoin because it makes
sense in all of those occasions
but i don't use anything else i don't
have a need for anything else i can
imagine a very rare scenario where i may
use monero but just because i'm
too much of a [ __ ] to use bitcoin in a
private way
but i don't really use other
cryptocurrencies and i wonder if
people are using perhaps bitcoin cash a
bit out of a desire to keep it going
right give it some kind of energy
but ultimately i just kind of i think
it's
you know let me add another thing in
their pump as well i just did um a guest
on a show today they want to do a
bitcoin segment
and they said try to explain uh bitcoin
and i you know i did the whole it's just
like gold but digital
if i'd have been trying to explain it as
a way of doing payments and censorship
resistant payments i think i would have
struggled because
everyone right now can benefit from a
digital code especially with all the
money printing
but do do people really care about
censorship resistance payments i don't
think
i think i think in an ideal world
they'll have it but they don't really
care i mean day to day everyone is just
spending money normally so
i just i i think the project's screwed
long term
yeah i mean look i you know i i told
roger on it that obviously we have a
difference of opinion as to the future
outlook of that and and frankly it's
uh something mark is going to decide so
so you know it is what it is
um the the part that i think uh people
have to
remember is uh one of the mistakes that
many investors
um or you know market participants will
make is
they look at something as a snapshot
today
right and so you know this is the um the
paul krugman the internet will be never
be more important than the fax machine
type stuff right this is
uh looking at um you know bitcoin in
2014 at
in a single point of time and what i
think that
uh technology folks uh are very good at
doing because they've seen the pattern
so many times
is they're able to understand what this
thing is today
what are the structural components of it
and
what foundation does that lay for it to
evolve
over the coming you know 10 20 30 years
and
to me uh we all like to debate the
merits of what can it do right now this
second
but when you kind of say hey look that's
not the right
conversation instead it is the
structural components
uh there is nothing you know more
powerful
valuable and exciting uh in my opinion
than
that structural component of bitcoin and
it really just comes down to three
things right one is
it has a fixed supply which you know as
we talked about
um the money printing two is uh
it's fully decentralized so the
decentralization is actually the
you know then kind of the the
ramification of that is censorship
resistant payments and kind of all that
stuff but decentralization of the
structural piece
and then the third thing and probably
the most important in my mind
is it has market adoption and i think
one of the key pieces uh that those who
are not students of history on a
technology front uh
miss is the best technology does not win
right that that is a complete fallacy it
is
what gets adoption and you can go back
to the vhs first beta max you can go you
know all through history you can go
through all these different things
but money specifically is
a belief system it is a network effect
business right and
it's very viral in the sense of you send
it to people and kind of do all this
stuff
and because of that i think that bitcoin
actually has a much bigger advantage
uh than people realize nothing to do
with technology
it is simply the market adoption right
and that's frankly one of the things
that roger and i kind of came to an
agreement in terms of where
our difference of opinion lies right he
believes that technology is important i
believe that market adoption is
important in the early days and we'll
see how it plays out but
you know that that's kind of one of the
key differences in opinion
do you think he got anything out of it
do you think because i haven't i might
go and watch the rest of it now but do
you think by the end of it he left
with any a change of opinion of his
any potential insights into where he
should look at things differently or do
you think
he just came to replay his message and
were
left exactly the same um
i don't think that uh and i didn't
approach it as like let me try to
convince you like
we were pretty clear during it in terms
of uh
i didn't want to get into some you know
argument or even really debate it was
more of just like let's outline
you know the facts and there were people
who scoff at the idea of facts right
but just like what do you believe what
do other people believe
why here is the you know kind of
different options somebody has
and why do you believe you're right and
why do you believe you know why did
other people believe they're right
and i think we did that um hopefully
what
uh he got out of it is uh one
i think that somebody who uh is in the
position that roger is in
uh he really believes in the ultimate
goal
of a digital decentralized currency
being adopted globally
right the disagreement is on the path to
get there but but kind of the finish
line i actually think that
bitcoiners roger and many other people
all agree on that
um and i think that people who uh are
seen as either controversial
um or uh you know just
there's a lot of backlash right and kind
of negative um
feedback they just want to be heard
right and i think that
in many cases uh roger when he's
been asked to do interviews or whatever
because of the environment
in which the interview gets done it's
just turns into this argument
and kind of is very unproductive and
he's actually not able to
articulate why um and so that's my
biggest hope is that
everyone was able to just clearly
understand like hey here's why
uh and you know look frankly when i was
going into the interview
you know i didn't even told poland i was
like this either goes one of two ways
either this is going to turn out great
or this is going to be an absolute train
wreck
in terms of people are going to listen
to this and you know be mad at me and
kind of do all this stuff
but you kind of know that going into it
right so you kind of act
accordingly um and you know well the
ones who are mad at
you though they're mad at you before
it's done that's that's the
point of this stuff and also it's the
difference between what is an interview
and a debate
there are two entirely different things
some people want to debate
but they don't understand an interview
about constructing a series of questions
to take you through
almost like a timeline of a discussion
um and it's
it's constructed very differently from a
debate but the ones who didn't like it
made that decision because you did the
interview so that that was my whole
point
up front was there was a bunch of people
when i said the day before i was going
to do it
all you know upset and freaking out
stuff and i just responded a couple of
years hey
just wait till you hear it and then and
then if you don't like it knock yourself
out right then like yeah
all of your criticism is fair um and
again to some of those people's credits
um you know after they listen to it they
actually are like you know what
this is actually pretty good like i
actually thought it was you know
valuable and
uh i haven't heard roger articulate
ideas
in this way but whatever so to me like
that's a win
right um and i'm sure there's some
people who who don't agree with that but
that's fine
um you know you obviously can't please
everybody and no
you can't right i mean there's times
i've i've
thought about uh interviewing roger
again
um and people listen to this like oh
you're just turning back into a [ __ ]
coin podcast you just
and the point is is that like i would
interview i like interviewing a range of
people i like interviewing challenging
people i like interviewing different
you know i just interviewed stephanie
kelton who wrote a book about
mmt and she is a proponent of mmt
and um that's not a pro bitcoin
idea and a lot of people disagree with
that but i really enjoyed doing that
and there's times i've thought of doing
the roger interview again well i did a
second one once but
sometimes i'm like i just can't be
bothered to deal with the
backlash at times and i know i should
and most of the time i'm more out but
sometimes i'm just like i just can't be
bothered to deal with the backlash but
me as an interviewer like i don't know
if you think about this
i try to explain to people sometimes
whilst it's a bitcoin podcast
it's not a podcast just to cheerlead
bitcoin it's to provide content
entertainment um to challenge to
critique it's just do a bunch of things
right and sometimes you almost
want to get on what is considered i'm
going to say quote the villain
because the villains sometimes offer a
different perspective
again it goes back to um some of my
favorite questions to ask people
are what would it take to change to
change your mind on x
right so you just articulated why you
believe x what would it take to change
your mind
and it literally comes out do they
understand the the opposite argument
um and so i think you're right in that
when you bring somebody on who has that
opposite argument you're exposing people
to a more holistic picture
that doesn't mean necessarily they're
going to change their mind but they're
now better informed to
understand the counter argument right
and we live in a society that's so
uh like divisive right and it's just
like hey let me go to my echo chamber
and just kind of yell and scream
that i fear people
actually don't have the intellectual
rigor uh
to analyze situations because they're
not used to
understanding the counter argument and i
think that's
a crucial crucial part of of really
making any
uh kind of analysis or argument yeah i
mean also you just
doesn't matter what medium you're
following content on it can be youtube
it can be the news on tv it could be the
radio
the the journalists out there aren't
just interviewing the good guys
sometimes they're interviewing the
villains the bad guys the enemies
you know i think a lot of people would
like to hear an interview right now
with uh gizley maxwell she's a bad human
being she's
most likely a an enabler pedophile uh
possibly a pedophile herself
um but i think some people would like to
hear an interview with her she's a bad
human
but they want to hear her side so but it
seems we get into this like well the
bitcoin and people don't want to hear
from the bad dudes or the people they
perceive as bad dudes
completely agree what have you seen with
the podcast uh
during uh kind of this whole buyer
situation have
downloads gone up gone down have the
guests changed
what's been different for you yeah yeah
good question uh so they dropped it
first
i had a big drop at the i think it was
like
yeah i can tell you i think it was like
at the end of february just when it
started to kick off when it just started
to get a bit weird
i um yeah end of february had a big drop
of february and march were
you know just levels i'd seen like a
year ago
um but then because i couldn't travel i
focus on the podcast focus on the guests
and then i've seen growth again
i don't know if the growth is i think a
couple of things went on i think people
weren't going to the gym
they weren't commuting and they were
sitting watching netflix
and just kind of like just not consuming
podcasts as much
and then i think what happened was life
got a little bit back to normal and then
i think we got some new people
coming in who are kind of interested in
bitcoin because all the crazy [ __ ] going
on
and then um and then also i just like
focus on trying to get like
you know top guests on as well so now i
got back in growth i've just done the
numbers for
last month of the another record month i
don't know if i'm anywhere near you at
the moment because you've been
absolutely flying dude
yeah well we also have different
strategies right i i
um you know i make no secret about it
mine is
a volume game and uh i try to have as
many conversations as i possibly can uh
because to me the the podcast i think
some people take the
approach of like i'm going to make sure
that every single
episode i do is a hit and meets you know
kind of the the standard of um
in terms of the guest and the depth of
the conversation whatever
i think my promise to the audience is a
little bit different which is
i'm trying to learn as much as i
possibly can and so
my you know quality bar uh in terms of
maybe
audio or some other things maybe a
little bit lower
uh than others but it's because uh
i'm replacing with volume right so
whereas if i record an episode
and it takes you know two or three days
to edit and get perfect and if i wanted
to do transcripts and show notes and
kind of all that stuff
um i just couldn't do the volume that i
did right or i'd have to have a massive
team to kind of crank all that out
i think there's other people who say
well i want that stuff and they're
finally going to do one or two
conversations
uh per week and so um you know
ultimately like
you kind of find the audience that wants
what you want right yeah
i think that's the beauty of uh of
podcasts is
that there's so many different styles
there's so many different show formats
um people but you started to so when you
rebranded you started doing a little bit
more
you started getting some guests on you
want even like anything to do
i'd say even find this did you have like
a smelly a on
oh yeah my friend dustin yeah yeah uh so
i mean look but part of this
is uh you know again i want to
learn right and now take dustin's a good
example so
dustin is a guy who literally got
interested in wine as a
server at ruth chris steakhouse you know
20 years ago or whatever
uh ends up going through the entire
process becomes a master somalia
works at a number of the best
restaurants in the world
and then becomes the wine director
at 11 madison which was voted the number
one restaurant in the world
and then he left and he started um a
retail wine business called verve wine
and now it's working at a restaurant and
kind of all these other things
but a lot of people are like what the
hell could you learn from that guy if
you're not interested in wine
and i think there's kind of a couple of
key pieces which is
one every single place that guy's worked
for the last 15 years there's been this
obsession with perfection
right and just absolute everything has
to be perfect all the time
and so there's this like rigorous
process and the way they think about the
customer experience
and like all of that stuff uh two is
he's a highly successful person
right he literally uh has built a
business right he's worked at some of
the most successful businesses
and so i think you can learn from that
and then the third thing is he's just
got a very unique view of the world
right he's interested in finance and
technology and all this stuff but
he operates in a world that many of us
don't know uh
and and then you kind of overlay on top
of all of it he's one of 200
of the best people at his craft in the
world or there's only about 200 master
sommeliers in the world
and so you look at that you're just like
yeah i want to talk to that guy like
and you know i cheat because i know him
pretty well uh
and talk to him regularly but when he
comes on the podcast
my hope that people take away is not
like you know what's his favorite wine
it's all those other lessons and so
um yeah i won't have those people on
every day but
to have one on every once in a while i
think provides value and
you know between you and i uh and the uh
the five people listening to this
uh i don't care if they don't like it
like it's like this is for me to learn
and
people just gonna listen what's your
have you what's your like big plan
like because i know i'm i know exactly
where i'm going i know my strategy
i know what's your strategy what's your
strategy well my end goal is just to be
able to
make any content i want any day and not
give a [ __ ] if anyone wants to listen
you know a bit like how rogan does
comedians he does
mma but then he'll just do random people
like he but like mma and comedians is
his thing he does the other stuff
and he just does what the hell he wants
um i
i kind of want to get to that point i
want to do
i want to i want to interview rock stars
basically people who play the kind of
music i listen to
uh i think i've been interviewing a few
porn stars recently they're always
entertaining i want to do more of that
i want to do finance and corruption
really no just
every day just make whatever show i want
now i'm making enough money
and not give a [ __ ] about what anyone
says on twitter like that's the goal
um and that's what i'm trying to build
towards and i'm gradually getting to
you know i do the bitcoin and uh the
finance and the
corruption stuff through bitcoin and
defiance i am about to do with my first
i'm doing a
four-part documentary about a rock band
called the ghost inside starts next week
they're just crash this is a cool story
actually in 2015
they're screaming heavy metal band pop
right and they just released their album
and they broke out into the billboard
charts which is unheard of for that type
of band
then a year later they're in a fatal bus
crash it takes four years for them to
get back to play their next concert
because they're so [ __ ] from it
um so i'm doing a four-part thing about
that but like i am i'm
i'm putting these like little markers
around of the things i want to do and
then trying to get it to all kind of
converge like but i know i'm i'm
i know exactly where i'm going without
what i want to do um
and bitcoin is one of those things but
i'm wondering what's for you
what is your goal i don't know if i
necessarily have a
master plan um i think the kind of
guiding light if you will is uh i'm just
gonna do the things that i enjoy and
that i find
fun um you know i joke all the time but
it's not really a joke where i just say
look i create a lot of content i enjoy
doing it if one day i wake up and it's
not fun anymore i will stop that day
like i will not spend a single day doing
this if i'm not enjoying it and so
there could be a day in the future where
i wake up and i'm not writing the the
email anymore i'm not recording another
podcast see you guys later it was a
great run
you know i'm out and uh you know look i
hope that doesn't happen
right because i genuinely do enjoy this
stuff i've learned a lot
i've met some amazing people but uh but
but i think that's kind of like my first
rule
is i don't want to spend a minute doing
something i don't want to do
um the second piece is uh i think that
the world is changing
right and that change uh
i think i am one of many people that are
kind of living that you're another
um where the brand
or the thing that people want to pay
attention to is an individual not an
organization
and so if you kind of see that play out
um you know is that starting companies
of course is that creating content of
course
um is that kind of doing other things
that
individuals used to do i think so i just
don't have some like master plan
i just know that um you know we're
moving to a world where people want to
subscribe to
individuals right and uh all the content
stuff definitely helps with that
um all the social media stuff helps with
that um but but ultimately
you know i don't look at this as a
content game
i very much look at it as building a
massive massive audience
and then when you have the audience you
can figure out what are the things they
want
right and how do you solve problems for
them and do things like that
so you know i'm pretty transparent about
the fact that like there will be
companies that we create in the future
and things like that i have no clue what
those are today
um but but i'm not really worried about
it until you know some idea comes around
or somebody writes to me and says hey i
really want you to do x and i can't stop
thinking about it and then we'll do it
all right let's get into that weird
world stuff because and that's an
interesting point
because i think uh i think it's a
i think we could say we're all
let's go five six months back we're all
kind of on
autopilot prior to the pandemic right
you know the world's ticking along we're
all doing our thing
we know there's like some problems in
the economy the likes of
yourself and caitlyn long and travis
cling and rao powell
all been saying the same thing but i you
know always believed would just kind of
be okay and now we're at this
moment in time which is like history's
being rewritten i told my son i said
look
boy there's gonna come a time when you
have kids and you're going to tell them
about
what happened in 2020 and the pandemic
how the world shut down because
it's completely unprecedented in our
time
but i kind of get this feeling we're not
going to come out the end of this
pandemic
and it's back to normal i think there's
going to be a lot of expectations for a
different kind of world and maybe it
will be
maybe it will be a normal world or maybe
we'll go to a more authoritarian world
or maybe we'll go to a world of more
liberty and that that i don't know
but i feel like we're living through
that moment now
and i i don't think it's going to be a
smooth path i think a lot of weird and
scary shit's going to happen over the
next few years and
i've got like a mixture of fear and
excitement
about it all a bit more on the fear side
because revolutions are always bloody
but also a bit more excitement because
hopefully we can dismantle
or not we i mean hopefully some of the
the [ __ ] stuff around government and
finance and central banking
begins to be dismantled but it's a weird
time dude
yeah i mean you know it it really
depends on your perspective
and the thing i keep telling myself is
we live in the safest most prosperous
time in human history
right and generally uh the trend is that
that will continue
and are there short periods in certain
geographic locations where that's not
true
or you kind of reverse uh course of
course
but overall humanity
continues to get better because it just
gets safer continues to get more
prosperous
um and i think that that's like one
thing in the back of my head that at
least just like yeah just chill out like
it's gonna the world's gonna keep
spinning uh at the same time
um i do think that in these moments of
uncertainty
and chaos uh there are things that
happened in history
that uh are not just in history books
and what i mean by that
is you know i always ask people like
you've read about the american
revolution right as an example
like there was a bloody war and that set
up america
and kind of freedom and everyone knows
the whole story
what makes you think that there won't be
more
american revolutions in the future not
necessarily involving america but that
type of situation
uh all around the world and again
doesn't mean that they're all gonna
happen tomorrow all at the same time and
you know there's gonna be mass chaos and
it's gonna look like the purge
but it does mean that um you know
history repeats itself and so
do you think currencies are gonna fail
in the future of course we're gonna have
currencies
which ones when all that stuff is hard
to tell is there gonna be
violent conflict of course where with
who
when that's all up for debate it's all
up for um
a lot of kind of people smarter than i
but but i think that even with
those things happening uh we will
continue to live in a better and better
world
uh technology is a big piece of that and
so it's one of these weird situations
where
i don't worry so much about uh kind of
the big
picture stuff um i'm aware of it i
obviously talk about it a lot
but when i go to sleep at night i just
worry about myself
right and when you do that i think that
is
a very kind of sobering calming effect
of like
am i good if i'm good all right like
i'll keep figuring it out for me
and i can't you know affect what
a central bank does or what a country
does or
um you know prevent a war from occurring
like if those things happen they happen
and
and i'll respond along with everybody
else accordingly um but but it
ultimately is just like
you're like in control yourself right so
just worry about that
i think there's a slight i think i've
got a slightly different outlook and i
tell you why because when i go to bed i
have to think about two little people as
well
so i've got a 16 year old got two years
of school left and he has a choice of
kind of
university which i for obvious reasons
don't want him to go to
because yeah he's not going to be a
doctor he's not going to be a lawyer so
he doesn't need to
he's got creative skills and i've got a
daughter who's 10
and so i have to go i go to bed worrying
about
the world where they're going to be in
in say
you know five to ten years time so
you know can you change it like that's
like and when i say i worry about myself
like obviously i worry about myself
paulina
you know my brothers my parents like you
know there's a small group of people
that i include in
worry about me but like can you change
the world
uh in the sense of uh reverse course
from any of that happening
no no of course not but there's that
there is at that point like i don't vote
right just
i just got no interest anymore but
people say well
people say well if you don't vote you
can't influence and democracy is based
on the fact that enough people do go and
vote you get that kind of consensus from
it
um you know if we all yeah for if we
look at something like
global warming and i'm you know a huge
hypocrite because in how i fly et cetera
but if we all do nothing
and if you believe global warming is
caused by humans then it will get a lot
worse
if you think i can't individually make a
difference so you have to do a little
bit
and i just think i think the thing with
kids it's not that i think can i change
the world to make it a better place i i
obviously i can't
but are there little things i can do to
make the part of the world i live
in a better place and maybe that's maybe
that's first starting with the the
boundaries of my house
can i do things in that to make the
world a better place for my children can
i
you know then outside that boundary
around my friends and social communities
and then
you know so what are the things we can
do better but i just i do worry
i do worry for what kind of world we're
heading towards
and what opportunity they will have and
it's multiple things
like it's not just you know it's you've
got to think about
opportunities because of ai and
automation you know what kind of
what kind of career should i be kind of
nudging them towards so they have
opportunity
what kind of things should i be exposing
to them in the world and telling them
not to worry about
i mean maybe just tell them to avoid
politics
yeah but but i think that like this is a
perfect example right so
take global warming as a uh as kind of a
talking point right
yeah we don't know what's true
right and and people get very uh
sensitive about this
but i can show you studies on both sides
of the argument
and also i can show you studies that
uh are very compelling from very well
respected people
that would disprove the other argument
right so kind of the
there's tons and tons of data tons of
studies um
and ultimately i'm not a scientist right
and so
my ability to sift through all that and
find quote the truth is
you know little to none what i do think
is
you can simply say well if it's true or
it's not
is my life going to change if i
basically default to it's true
and i act accordingly i don't think that
that's going to
uh necessarily be a bad thing right so i
can basically act as if it's true even
if it's not my life isn't going to
materially change
and uh if it happens to be true then i
kind of did my part
now what is doing your part and i think
that this is the
the the kind of
maybe not inaccurate thinking but it's
where people
uh because we're human they want to feel
like they have
something to do right and so uh one of
the most popular things around
global warming is i'm not gonna fly okay
if you don't fly do you think the
plane's still gonna fly of course it is
right and so unless you're going to get
uh enough drop in demand to remove
20 of flights for an airline company you
choosing to fly
or not is not going to change anything
right and
people don't like that answer because it
feels like no i can have you know i can
have an impact right like we're
constantly told you can have an impact
you can do something
but i think that where you can have an
impact
is it's less about uh on the micro level
for a lot of these world
problems like no you actually can't
change
an election as an individual right
you're part of a much bigger thing
you can't change global warming as an
individual right by just simply not
flying or something like that
where if you want to have an impact i
always tell people stop being on the
defensive side and go play offense and
so if you want to change global warming
like go build a company where you can
get access to lots of resources
to actually have a material impact on a
macro level
right if you want to change politics
voting is uh something that you are one
of
millions that are going to do right so
actually if you if you go vote or you
don't
it's not going to change the election
right in many many cases uh
but if you want to change the political
thing then go
run to be or go work on a campaign right
like there's almost this feeling of um
you've got to be
much more strategic and i think
intelligent about the impact that you
want to have it's not
you know did i put things in the
recycling bin or not because the the
dent that you can make in the problem is
so small
if that's the thing that you really care
about then like then go actually work on
it
and the problem with that is uh one you
find out that
uh if there's more friction now some
people don't really care right like yeah
it's easy it's easy to like
yeah like uh okay cool put in the
recycling bin but if you want me to like
go somewhere on saturday and like
actually do something that really
matters like oh i don't care about the
problem that much
and the second thing is uh there's only
so many problems you can focus on
right so you see somebody down you say
what are all the issues you care about
like they'll have this laundry list of
things everything from
you know social justice issues to
environmental issues to whatever
and then you say okay but you can only
work on one what's the one issue
and you find like they actually probably
do have the one thing they care about
more than everything else
but it's like all right then go devote
your time energy and resources to that
one thing
and actually make an impact rather than
trick yourself
into having you know little to no impact
on a whole bunch of things
right so i think that the focus uh is a
really big piece of it
yeah look i know you're right i know
you're right
and it's just i don't know i just think
about it differently
like we've lived through ourselves
like we're a similar age we've lived
through probably the best time ever
as you said more prosperous more
opportunity
it's cheap to travel the world like i
think i went to 18 countries last year
um we've lived in such an amazing time
where technology is incredible
relatively safe in the countries we're
in
i just feel very lucky to do that but i
i've got a feeling
like definitely the next decade is not
going to be as good there is going to be
this sharp
economic impact i mean what was that
what was the gdp
for like nine percent 11 in the
like u.s uh oh uh the drop in gdp for q2
is
uh negative 9.5 which is yeah 32.9
percent
uh annualized uh yeah so what was it
the great recession was 6.5 yeah but
but here's the thing right so like and
again this is where you start getting
into the nuances all
of this stuff is we had a
9.5 drop in actual q2 gdp
yet billionaires made over half a
trillion dollars
at the same time right yeah but we know
why well well but but here's the whole
thing
is you can't stick a black and white
label on the situation
because if we keep heading in the
direction we're heading it actually will
be
a fantastic decade for a lot of people
right and it'll be a horrible decade for
another big part of the population
and so let's just say for you know the
basis of this conversation it's 50 50.
right 50 of people are gonna do
fantastic because they're the ones that
own
investment assets you know they haven't
know how money works all that kind of
stuff
and the fifty percent live paycheck to
paycheck have only cash savings no
investment assets
they're going to suffer like you can't
say
oh it's going to be a bad decade
if i don't think that's going to happen
what do you mean
well i don't think 50 of people are
i know you said for the sake of
conversation but i don't think 50 of
people over the next decade are gonna
have a great time
at fifty percent they're gonna strike i
just think i think it's gonna be an
aggregate drop
for most people like it's gonna be so
we're gonna have a lot of people out of
work
a lot of people struggling to get by you
know we live in a country where
whether whatever you think of socialism
or social safety nets we have them
we have people who rely on welfare
programs
more people are going to rely on that
but the government's going to have less
money
um and i think we're going to see a lot
of social unrest well i mean we're
already seeing that especially in the us
so i don't see it playing out like that
that's the point like i am prepared now
for a for a tough decade coming
but in my mind i don't think that that's
different right like like that's just a
natural progression
of a society which is so in the united
states uh for example
40 of government spending is on people
over the age of 65
right so kind of a lot of money is spent
on an overpopulation
obviously the baby boomer generation is
going to continue to feed into that
and there's many people who think by
2030 the amount of money spent on
people over the age of 65 out of the
government but should be 50 so
you know kind of 25 increase over the
next 10 years
that is just natural in terms of your
demographics get older already a big
part of your population
now with that said you kind of have two
options
right is either one if you want to
continue to have the um the economic
boom
that let's say over the last you know 10
12 years like you just moved to a
different country
right so so if you get really scared
like you can move to a country where
uh the economic uh prosperity shifts
right and people will debate what that
country would be but that's fine
or what you can do is you can understand
structurally how it works
and if you understand structurally how
it works there are going to be people
who do really really well
if you're right in the scenario that you
described and i think that's the the key
piece is
this is not a access type
situation this is simply an education
problem
right which is people don't understand
what
is happening and because they don't
understand they're going to get hurt
if they understand what's happening they
can make
very easy decisions to actually benefit
from the situation rather than
be hurt by it and so if we can change
that education
you know how what percentage of
population is educated on this stuff if
you can
increase that percentage you can
actually shift it from a negative
situation to a positive situation
that's just very hard to do
yeah i guess i don't know
differently from you um because it's
little things like i said about the kids
like i'm thinking
i remember i had this company at this
agency in london pop and
we used to put out a and this is we're
talking seven years ago we'll put out a
new job
position and it'll be it's a junior and
we get 80 to 90 applications for one
role
and it'll be people with degrees in the
first and second or third and
i'll tell you a funny story actually um
one guy who got one of the jobs just
came and knocked on the door
and just said look i've seen the jobs up
um can i just talk to you about it and i
was like
yeah of course and he got the job there
and then and another guy did an
application as an infographic who got a
job
but the point being is we got a lot of
applications we just have nothing in the
uk there was a role for a receptionist
had a thousand applications
like there's gonna be fewer jobs
available a lot more people going for
those jobs so i'm in that place i'm
thinking
right i've got kids leaving school in
two years and then eight years
you know if they're not going into
higher education what are the skills
they need
what are the skills they're going to
need to be have an opportunity to get an
interesting job
you know a well compensated job or even
a job they just enjoy
because it is going to be competitive
and the workplace is changing
yes and no right which is i think that
there's going to be less
of the same type of jobs but there's
going to be much more of the new type of
jobs and what i mean
so so think back um there's a point in
time in uh in the united states where
98 of people were farmers right
obviously that's not true anymore and so
i i don't know what the number is two
percent five percent you know whatever
it is now
but that's not like all the jobs went
away it's just that
those people went and found different
types of jobs and so if you look
you know again let's call it 20 30 years
out what are the things that are going
to be in high demand well obviously
anything around
technology will be incredibly uh
important
um and so you can kind of just go
through everything from
design to computer science to you know
analytics like all of that type of stuff
those jobs if you go and you talk to
companies many of them will say
we can't find enough people right and
that's why they're paying them so much
money and they're doing all this kind of
stuff and so
i think that it's very vertical specific
um
and unfortunately and kind of what
you're highlighting is the people who
are
uh out of work right now tend to be
service hospitality you know kind of
lower socioeconomic status
you know kind of the people at the
lowest end of a corporate
ladder and those jobs are heavily
commoditized because there's a million
other people who can do the same job and
so you put out a receptionist and you
get a thousand applications
if you put out you know uh i need a
self-driving
um autonomous vehicle engineer right
you actually don't get any applications
and you got to go try to find somebody
at another company and recruit them to
leave
right okay it's it's not fair to say
uh you know hey peter your 16 year old
should learn how to be a
uh you know autonomous driving engineer
in the next two years
uh if he's not one interested in it two
you know hasn't already spent time doing
it like all
there's challenges here but i do think
what it hints at is
as a society we are going to have to
retrain
entire generations with new skills for
those new jobs
it will happen it's just how quickly
does it happen and who are the people
who get retrained versus the people who
get left behind
again like these transitions they just
happen over and over again in history
sounds pretty you know bleak but that's
just what happens
yeah i guess i guess you're as i'm not
even saying
optimistic versus pessimistic although
i'm being pessimistic i think you're
just saying
it's just the way it is [ __ ] will figure
it out we'll figure out
it it's a thing where um
i generally believe humans
solve the problems that they face right
uh yeah
and that's part of the beauty of the
human race
uh but also i think that uh we have a
lot of recency bias
right we always think that like what
we're going through is different than
what's ever happened before um and there
are differences
right for sure uh we've never had a
global pandemic when the internet
allowed information to
uh you know kind of be disseminated so
quickly and then have a federal
government willing to step in and
respond with quantitative easing so
there are nuances in there that are
different than any global pandemic
in the past but at the same time like
there's been plenty of civilizations
that have dealt with
some sort of you know massive public
health crisis
and so what we need to be smart about is
learning from history at the same time
understanding what are the unique
advantages we have today in a situation
i actually think one of the crazy things
is uh
in past retrainings of a society
we didn't have the internet right and so
like it's a massive advantage for us
now are people going to be self-starters
how do we
deal with the cost structure for that
you know how do you get certification if
you're not going to a university like
there's things that need to be figured
out
in there uh but i generally believe that
entrepreneurs will figure that stuff out
like they're the people who solve the
problems in society
um and so we should encourage as many of
those people to step up and do that as
possible
everything from you know just emotional
support to capital to other things as
well
all right man we need to do some bitcoin
in before we finish this all right will
you go
you started there but i wanted to talk
about roger no you tell me what do you
think is going on right now look we
we had a 2017 you know 2018
we went through some good times then
then we had this bear market that seemed
to go on forever
now like we seem to be back on the rise
the timing seems right in that we seem
to be coming out of a bear market and
also
you know there's there's definite
signals within the market for why
people should be investing in scarce
assets well i'll say that broadly
because
i still believe gold has a role to place
this play despite what other people
think
but like what do you make of what's
going on
before i answer that and i forget if you
listen to
my podcast you should go subscribe to
peter's podcast
what bitcoin did he has awesome guests
and he's awesome as you can tell
so please go subscribe and vice versa if
you listen to peter's podcast
go subscribe to mine that's the whole
point of us doing a joint podcast
no no once you subscribe to mine you
don't need pumps anymore
[Laughter]
fair fair fair it's so funny you know i
troll you know i troll the [ __ ] out
i love it yeah but like some people
don't get it they like
think they think it's real well you know
you know you have to say to those people
oh it we're having fun you won't like it
right like
all right come on tell me about bitcoin
what do you make what did you make on
that
uh this was the easiest call in history
and and i say that half joking but last
year
i wrote multiple times in may june and
july about
we are ending we're getting near the end
of an economic cycle right we've been
this long 10-year bull market all this
stuff
and at the end central banks only have
two tools to deal with
that downturn they can manipulate rates
so they can print money
and i said look i think that they're
going to have to do that
at some point in the coming months it is
likely
that it is going to coincide within a
90-day window
of the bitcoin habit and so
one of the things that i wrote was uh
dropping rates printing money into
having all occurring around the same
time will serve as rocket fuel for
bitcoin
now there are plenty of people who are
going to hear me say this they're like
well how did you know a global pandemic
was going to happen
i didn't obviously right nobody knew but
that simply served as the catalyst to
drive the end of the bull market so
there was already a bunch of issues you
had inverted yield curves
you had all the repo market gyrations
and kind of structural issues
you had an all-time record high of ceos
leaving their roles like
there was a bunch of these um you know
uh
issues or alarm bells going off all
through the end of last year and in the
beginning of this year
so we were getting towards the end it
was just a matter of what was going to
be the thing that accelerated that or
caused it to happen
and so now what we see is a world where
gold bitcoin real estate are all going
to do really well
right because you simply can't print
trillions of dollars of a currency and
have no impact on that currency
and so guess what we're literally seeing
the
exact theoretical kind of
impact of quantitative easing become
reality they printed trillions
the dollar got weakened when the dollar
weekends asset prices all explode
it's not because all of a sudden the
business is worth more money
it's literally because the dollar is
being devalued
same with bitcoin or gold there's not
much that's changed
from june 1st to january 30 or to july
31st with bitcoin
right the having had already occurred
it's pretty much doing exactly what it's
supposed to do
what's changing is one demand right so
there is some change in demand because
of what's going on the macro environment
but also the dollars being devalued and
that's where you get an explosion in
price
and so i tend to think that that thesis
from 2019
of they're gonna continue to keep rates
low they're gonna print money
and having occurred uh i think that 2021
is going to be absolute chaos uh in
terms of
a very uh high volatile
upward price movement of bitcoin but
ultimately it doesn't matter
right the us dollar value of bitcoin
doesn't matter this is a game of
accumulation and it's going to end up
being
what percent of the 21 million bitcoin
do you own right like that that's what i
think of
i don't worry about the us dollar value
all i continue to think about
is what is the number of bitcoin i own
divided by 21 million
and when you think of it that way all of
a sudden you start to realize do i own
more or less
than i did yesterday or the day before
the week before or whatever
and if you have that mentality kind of a
bitcoin denominated mentality i think
you'll end up doing pretty well
well yeah i mean i i never think that
i've actually got particularly a large
amount of bitcoin but if i looked at the
gold market and my percentage of bitcoin
was in the gold market i'd be like
[ __ ] come i mean i'm good here right
so this is right there and look here
here's what i continue to tell people
name to me a business that was analog
and got digitized and the digital
version
is smaller than the analog version
it doesn't happen right and it's because
digitization brings all kinds of
advantages it's a market expanding
technology
and so you know their people will debate
what the size of the gold market is but
let's just use easy numbers let's say
that it's eight uh trillion dollars that
puts bitcoin at depending on how many
are lost or stolen or whatever
you know 400 450 000 u.s dollars today
do you think that bitcoin's only going
to be the equivalent of the gold market
i don't know right it's
better it's going to capture more market
now when does that happen i don't that
might take 50 years to happen
right but when you think of it that way
you're like okay again don't worry about
the individual
day-to-day price movements or any other
stuff just look at the underlying
structural uh kind of foundation and
then look at
how does technology evolve right this is
a
uh a technology evolution story in terms
of market adoption and things and we've
seen it play out
over and over and over again airbnb
biggest hotel yeah doesn't know any
hotels right uber
biggest taxi company but doesn't own any
tax like we've seen this happen
so many times uh and i don't think it's
different this time
what's the equivalent of that bitcoin
biggest bank doesn't own any branches
yeah or
or in the sense of um
if you think of bitcoin as uh one day
i believe we will say bitcoin is the
largest currency in the world
in terms of uh market cap and it will
have
no one controlling it right like i
fundamentally believe i my worry is
i won't be alive to see that day because
it may take that long
right that's annoying at in my early 30s
let's say that i live a great life i got
50 years right
is bitcoin going to end up uh
kind of ascending to the global reserve
currency status
in the next 50 years and will we see it
eclipse a 80 90 trillion dollar market
cap
i don't know but if you said to me
between now and the rest of human his
uh you know humans future potential or
you know future years
absolutely no question in my mind that's
gonna happen it's just will it happen my
lifetime or not
and so by the way if it doesn't happen
in my lifetime
still being along for the ride's gonna
end up being pretty good i think
yeah because it's like we're along for
half the lifetime right like
of getting there i'm getting there like
the next yeah
i'm pretty sure with my 10-year thesis
in 10 years time i'm going to be very
happy with my investment i think my kids
are going to be even happy and want me
to
to die because they can have all my
bitcoin but
i think we're going to be happy all
right so listen look
one second
peter has gotten up run away
who knows what he's doing maybe he's
getting getting me a gift
he's doing an interview the children are
going to have to
understand literally i told them
i'm doing an interview leave me alone
and they're back they're back
knocking on the door wanting my shield i
can hear you i can leave your lovely
wife in the background
she's sitting over there uh laughing at
the fact that i am uh
talking about uh children shall i say
congratulations
peter says congratulations she says
hello
whenever the planes are flying again
we're going to go to mcdonald's and
celebrate
times square mcdonald's going to be
popping one day again
is it back open yet uh yeah i think it's
open but
you know they got all the crazy rules uh
can't sit inside all that kind of stuff
how are you coping with that oh it's
fine
look i eat uh domino's every saturday
sometimes mcdonald's i'm living a great
life
i know you love a mcdonald's all right
man well listen look
what would it take to change your mind
you said this at the start what's gonna
take to change your mind
are you following the d5 stuff will you
like [ __ ] that
no all right so horror we need to settle
this for a second i'm not against
defy at all i actually think it's going
to be super super valuable
again again it's like when roger and i
talk about a digital decentralized
currency ended up being
adopted globally super important thing
it's going to happen that's you know
called the finish line or the goal or
milestone or whatever
it's just how do we get there that's how
i feel about the d5 stuff
d5 and i think part of my issue with how
it's being categorized right now
is the ethereum community thinks that
they have a monopoly on that terminology
right they they're using d5 as
a uh synonym for ethereum
and it's not right and it's why i say
things like
bitcoin is the most valuable defy
application and they all freak out all
right what do you mean whatever
decentralized finance right the core
of finance is money and yeah the most
decentralized
most valuable application that is
decentralized is bitcoin
so it's intellectually dishonest when
they say
no it's not and ultimately what they're
saying is that they're
upset right they don't want d5
to actually be successful anywhere else
other than ethereum
and so we've made plenty of investments
in companies that are building on top of
ethereum
that support ether that uh use some
version of a decentralized application
or do something right so again don't
listen to what i say just watch what we
do with the money
and we're making investments we
obviously think that there's value there
but i'm not convinced that d5 is an
ethereum
only thing right obviously bitcoin it
proves that
and so what you end up getting is you
end up getting
this religiousness about
defy that completely ignores reality and
also is intellectually dishonest when
talking about it
and so what i think is going to end up
happening is that is going to be
detrimental
to that entire space what i hope
occurs is that there's enough people who
are rational
and who kind of understand the
structural pieces and that it ends up
not
actually mattering right but if you
literally you can go i tweeted the other
day and said bitcoin is the most
uh valuable uh defy application and
literally it was like a bunch of eth
trolls just being like you're an idiot
you don't know what you're talking about
whatever
like do you understand what the
definition of decentralized finances
are you triggering bitcoiners and these
heads at the same time now
no because i think that i think that
bitcoin people
have this belief that if something came
along
that had more market adoption and had
better core um
kind of aspects to it than bitcoin they
they want to see a digital currency
succeed
right and so i don't think actually that
bitcoiners for the most part
are married to the idea of bitcoin or
nothing
right i just think that they're very
very convinced that bitcoin is the
solution
and by the way the market has validated
that yeah okay
on the d5 side many of those people i do
not believe
actually are defy or
bust i think that they're ethereum or
bust and i think that's very dangerous
so what would it take to change your
mind that bitcoin
i think that there's three yeah there's
three key things so one is a self
like a very serious self-inflicted wound
in terms of some sort of bug or
something introduced in the
development process of bitcoin right so
no no i'm like i'm like the other way
i'm saying
what do it take to change your mind that
like bitcoin is the only thing you
should focus on and put money into
me meaning what would it take to
convince me to do something else
yeah just to forget all these [ __ ] coins
oh you're saying
what would it take to convince me that
bitcoin is only thing worth putting
money into yeah
oh i mean look that's what basically
what we do we we hold no tokens in
uh from an investment standpoint uh
other than bitcoin right the
the actual investments that we make are
uh bitcoin
i own nothing other than bitcoin and so
i thought you were putting money into
default stuff you've been into companies
built
into companies yeah into companies right
so like that that's my whole thesis
uh is bitcoin will be the next global
reserve currency
don't know how long it takes but that's
going to happen and then what actually
the value that accrues is into the
infrastructure
right and so it goes back to the same
example of like
if you invested in the seed round of
kraken or coinbase or
any of these companies and bought
bitcoin on the same day the equity
investment actually has outperformed
the just holding bitcoin interesting
so when you look at it from that
standpoint it's like okay hold on a
second here
now you can invest in 10 early stage
startups and
nine go to zero and you gotta make sure
you're in the one that actually does
that right so that there's some nuance
to it
but it's just a belief that
infrastructure is
always uh a much um a very valuable kind
of profitable strategy
uh and then bitcoin is going to be more
valuable in the future than it is today
that's my belief
right and so are other things going to
go up
of course like it take uh ethereum for
example right or ether
uh everyone's yelling and screaming
about how it's going up in value so much
well yeah of course because bitcoin is
going to lead in terms of bitcoin
having and the money printing and all
this stuff will move
and then the money although the smaller
market cap assets
will just move more in u.s dollar terms
but i think that
like what it shows is those people are
looking at this from an investment
return perspective
i think that the bitcoin community like
you said they're not going to sell
right the the number of bitcoins that
have not moved in over a year
is like 64 65 the highest it's ever been
they're not going to sell and so it
doesn't matter what the percentage
changes if you're not going to sell
because ultimately what you're doing is
you're denominating how many bitcoin do
i have
i don't hear a lot of people in other
assets in the crypto world talking like
that
right and so what ultimately ends up
occurring here and i think is very
important
is when you look at a market when things
go down
the the blue chip large market cap
assets
move down the least right and all the
small caps they
you know fall really fast when you then
go into a bull market
the large caps they move the least right
and the small caps explode up in value
it's a market cap thing
and i think that's what we're seeing in
crypto so if you said to me you know
am i surprised that whether i'm not
gonna name some of the other ones but
there's plenty of them that are you know
exploding
it's of course because if i took a
million dollars and i put it in that
verse a million dollars in bitcoin
of course i'm gonna move the market much
more of the small cap asset
because it's simply got a smaller market
cap and i think that's what we're seeing
play out again not a bad thing it's just
that if you're a student of history and
understand how markets work like
not surprised i think we get a new
all-time high this year
i could see that i i don't know if it's
going to happen like you know look
the only thing have you said any sort of
uh anything around price other than
all-time high by the end of this year
no because it's so difficult you know i
was having this conversation with my son
yesterday it was like
like i said look there's people who
think the price can go to you know
30 50 even a hundred thousand dollars
he's like he's like would you sell
something i said well that's a really
tough thing because
you could sell at 50 and it goes to 100.
so i just don't sell
i just i just know that i a bit like you
said
you know what's your percentage i just
need no i need to have as much of it
as i need and then i'll sell it when i
have to sell it
and that's what i'll do because i have
to sell at that point until then i i
won't
but i i think we're going to a new
all-time high this year
but i think if it happened i think it
probably happens before
the election which i know sounds soon
but to be honest based on the previous
time we went from
12 to 20k it was pretty easy um but i
think it happens before the u.s election
because i
think i think the stock market has to
stay
at a high value for donald trump which
means yes
and i mean they're negotiating another
stimulus package right
um so i just think there's going to be a
lot more money trillions more printed
before the us election
and then i think we'll get a new
all-time high before the election
because of that
and i think people are very aware now i
think the gold price has been very
helpful
because i've been telling people about
the bitcoin price i don't care tell
about the gold price
they understand and then you talked
about bitcoin being digital gold
in terms of where it can go i've got no
idea um
i don't know what like happens to
liquidity so say if bitcoins at like
100k and somebody thinks [ __ ] i've got
one bitcoin i'm on 100k and they might
want to sell
i don't know if that people have that
kind of like psychological reaction to
it and therefore
you've got a lot of selling pressure i
don't understand all that stuff
all i do think is i think we get a new
all-time high before the election i
could be wrong
and i think next year is going to be
[ __ ] crazy what about you
so the short term is much harder
obviously uh yeah the only number that
i've said is
i do think we'll hit 100 000 u.s
exchange
uh you know price or value by the end of
2021. so december 31st 2021 we'll have
hit 100k
we'll still be above it i have no clue
but like that will have happened
beforehand
um i definitely can see a world
where uh the current administration
essentially you know people hate when i
describe this way buys votes
by continuing to pump the uh the equity
markets because it's not really pumping
the economy
it's the easiest thing they can do it's
the best campaign that they can do right
is
if you're sitting there and 50 plus
percent of the country says i'm getting
rich
i like this guy right like i don't care
about all the other dumb things or
whatever everyone's complaining about
like
my portfolio keeps going up so this guy
is good for me right yeah
um you know i think there's a lot of
people who disagree with that they're
not happy that people think that way
but at the same time i think generally
people are very
um kind of self-centered and they say
who's gonna do the best for me
and the the crazy part of all of that is
uh
there's a scenario again i'm not
necessarily convinced that this is the
scenario but one of the possibilities
is they absolutely pump the asset prices
going into the election
and as soon as the re-election happens
they basically take their foot off the
gas
and there's some sort of crash right
yeah and asset prices
possible but but who knows what's going
to happen i think that the the beauty
here is
the one thing we know for sure is that
they are only making
900 bitcoin a day right now and six
months ago they were making 1800
and so demand just stays the same
naturally the price has to go up if
demand increases
the u.s dollar price has got to go up
and if they're going to print money
i think demand is going to continue to
increase who wins the election
i think trump wins in a landslide really
oh yeah i don't think it's close to two
reasons
uh if you turn on american television
right now nobody's talking about
anything but trump
it's the exact same thing that he he did
before right he's just dominating
headlines
uh and the second thing is i think that
the current democratic
nominee uh is one of the worst people
they could have put forward
oh it's terrible you know i've got half
a bitcoin on him losing
on trump losing what's your argument for
why he loses
so i had i've got it like
about threefold right um i think the
timing of the pandemic second wave is
terrible for him
um i think that's really bad for them
i assumed i i thought the democratic
party would replace biden
i just assumed they would because it's
so obvious he's
not the right um candidate for the job i
mean
you know as everyone has pointed out he
he can barely talk sometimes he's
obviously got
cognitive issues so i assume they
replace him i kind of thought cuomo
would get it
and i'm not that i'm a family guy let's
see everything i have to
say to people is like i'm not a fan of
the democratic party i thought trump was
losing that's why my bet was i'm better
on trump losing it
um so i thought i thought it was um
i thought it would be mainly down to a
better candidate coming in
um trump kind of having his meltdown and
basically the pandemic being very bad
timing
i'm not as confident as i was because it
feels like biden's
going to get the nod but i just assumed
they would be replacing him
i i completely agree i mean imagine
imagine a debate between donald trump
and joe biden
you'd have you have to get out you'd
have to get out the crime scene tape
like
and by the way that's not necessarily me
saying that he's even going to say
anything of substance
right it's just he just literally bully
the hell out of him uh
and and he understands how to get the
uh the sound fight right and people i
think are confused in like the debates
or things
they think that it's about who has the
better policy
that's not what it's about right no it's
it's basically who can
literally overpower the other person and
can get the sound bite
and can make people laugh and be you
know likeable all this kind of stuff
it's crazy absolutely crazy but that's
just the world we live in
i think there's another thing that
doesn't work in trump's favor and i'm
not into this whole like
election manipulation and uh voter fraud
i think there's
from when i looked at it when i did my
mnuchin work there's things going on on
both sides
i just think i think
people being able to or choosing to vote
from home or having to vote from home
because of the pandemic
that really suits the democratic party
over the republican party from
everything i've seen
republicans want to get out and vote in
person and
democrats are more likely to you're
going to see a higher
voter turnout on um mailing votes with
democrats and that's why i think trump's
scared of that so that's another thing i
could find there but
look it's fascinating it's like i
actually think that you're
right in the sense of uh
yes getting more democratic votes
is bad for trump i
think that i would argue more people
will
not vote so here's one of the things
that
uh i think people i think the argument
is that if you have mail in voting more
people will vote
i actually think it's the opposite which
is
although we all think it's easier to get
the piece of paper fill it out mail it
in
i think there's a lot of people who just
want to tell me where to go
right oh no i'm with you on that but i
think you once you might get a lower
turnout
you get a bigger drop off with
democratic uh sorry republican voters
like if there's a lower turnout if it's
mainly voting
it's worse for the democrats first with
the republicans because democrats are
more likely
to still use the mail and vote yes yeah
completely agree
yeah yeah so there's a lower voter
turnout but
it's it's skewed in one way but here's
the crazy part is
uh biden hasn't chosen a
vp yet i know i know and so
what i'm wondering is i don't think it's
over
yet in terms of their ability to switch
him out or to make him
the vp um i think cuomo
uh would be a natural potential person
for them to put in
uh i think that he's got a very very big
problem on his hands though
in terms of uh there's tens of thousands
of people
that died in new york because of his
decision to send
coveted patients back into the nursing
homes and i think that the
the republican party is sitting on that
they have not hammered him on it yet
and i think that if he gets put forward
you're gonna see i mean they're gonna
absolutely eviscerate him and say
you know there's blood on your hands and
kind of like go after him
and the sad part is like why do i think
that because i think that we haven't
seen the mud throwing yet
and like this is going to get really
nasty and when it gets nasty
there's going to be all kinds of
accusations like you haven't seen the
bill clinton epstein stuff yet
you haven't seen like all of this is is
just kind of waiting out there you can
see the ingredients
and uh like starting in september it's
gonna be like game on they're gonna
throw everything at the wall both
parties it's gonna be nasty
and then we'll get to the election well
i do hope the planes are flying because
i
i want to be in the us election night i
think i want to be there for a few days
i think it's going to be
fascinating to watch um i don't really
have
like i've got a bet but in terms of if i
wasn't having a bet
i couldn't honestly tell you who i would
prefer i i don't
i'm not a fan of either i probably i
mean i naturally feel like i swing
republican just because you know i like
i like republican states a lot when i've
been to places like texas or when i went
up to wyoming i just
really liked it i kind of felt
really at home in those kind of places
but like i don't know dude could be
wouldn't be
i think they're all the same yeah
and but i think i literally think
they're all the same what's the
difference between joe biden and donald
trump
like well it's not in terms of him i
think the politicians are all the same
but
like in terms of kind of like republican
ideals it's a little bit more like leave
me the [ __ ] alone let me get on with
work
but okay so i agree that idealistically
that that is what is happening but a
perfect example is
uh right now we're looking at a
situation where the republicans and
democrats
both want to print trillions of dollars
in the next diminished package
right yeah on that i think you're more
like if you ask me do you want to go
live in
portland oregon or do you want to go and
live in um
i don't know austin texas well i know
austin's austin's got the same problems
dallas texas i'll go to dallas right now
um but maybe like i don't know like
jackson hole yeah like i
i i would not want to go to any of these
places where these
crazy people are losing their [ __ ] and
writing every day at the moment it's
just it's a real turn off and i
i like portland i had a i've had a great
time in portland i like austin a lot but
i just don't want to be around these
places it's surreal
in in the sense of that you know being a
white dude who was born in america
grew up here uh was in the army the
whole thing and then you kind of see the
videos
um and i told point at one point like
it's almost like you can't believe that
that is america right like you used to
see those videos
uh i think i saw one uh from portland
right now i'm not an
expert by any means on kind of what's
happening there so you know kind of no
judgement that sense but
uh what they showed in the video if it
was real and all those things
you would expect to see in like a
war-torn country
you know somewhere else right that
didn't have democracy and can all this
crazy stuff and you're just like
man what is going on well at least in
the i guess in
those places do you think you you would
understand what they want or what
they're fighting about i've got
no idea what what the hell they want
there so
anyway bro listen look i gotta go and uh
i'm gonna go make dinner for these kids
all right well tell them i say hello you
should do an episode with your kids
i did a little one on um a little one of
them uh
youtube ones my son the other day asked
to buy some bitcoin
really because he's been yeah because
he's 16 he's been working he's earning a
bit of money and i was like
no no you don't need to do that you get
all my bitcoin but uh yeah no he's
interested they understand they
understand a few things
they um they know who satoshi is they
know there's 21 million they're
interested dude
they need some dinner that's that's
pretty good that they know all that
all right my friend if you listen to the
pump podcast go
subscribe to what bitcoin did if you
listen to what bitcoin did go subscribe
to the
podcast peter's a legend thanks for
having me man
always good to see you man hopefully see
you in new york at some time soon and
say hello to that lovely wife of yours
man and yeah go listen to pomp
um but just if you don't want us in bomb
just stick with mine because mine's a
bit better
see you guys take care